[Music]
all right in got caught news submitted
by turkey jerky disgusting
a group played a video of his bride
cheating during the wedding reception oh
man I wonder if this is the one I just
saw - does anyone have any reason why
these two shouldn't be happily wait let
him speak mouth actually it's a sex tape
is he like [ __ ] revenge Horning her
cuz that would [ __ ] my head right now
I'm like a cupid and if everyone is in
on it
nah allow all the guests yeah and other
family or that would slip mom and dad
wouldn't be over I'm not gonna let you
embarrass my [ __ ] daughter you see it
would be your your side of the family
everyone's you thinking everyone's the
[ __ ] Marines part where you can't
tell a secret or you go to the [ __ ]
you're going to Brig go to the prick you
have no rights alright so first of all
this this story takes place in China oh
yeah this is the one I thought yep so
there is footage they'll be playing for
you in a second like Felix the Cat
that's my goodness okay out the clock
yeah yes so apparently during the
wedding reception so the bride and groom
they were walking up to the stage you
know like what they're like hand in hand
or whatever and then as soon as they get
up to the stage cuz looks at her yeah
it's gonna be a beautiful day so then so
then the emcee is telling the rest of
the guests that they are about to view a
video of like how they met or like the
childhood or something and then so all
of a sudden this video starts playing
and you see the bride having sex with
another mate [ __ ] yes like making out
with the dude but it's a five minute
Sexy's that
in front of family and friends humiliate
this chick and so apparently they're
saying that it was her pregnant sister's
husband well she was what the [ __ ] is
going on
Wow yeah so that guy is probably at the
wedding too then yeah cuz I connected my
family next to her like he's by the
strip he's like he's like yes Marty so
it turns out I was probably their love
story oh Jesus oh I'm Way bigger all
scream oh my god the poor pregnant chick
was she still pregnant I think so yeah
okay she's like music that's me
yes I'll be I'll be yeah so so I've seen
some reports saying that it's her sister
daddy's pregnant but then others saying
that it was the groom's sister oh so I
don't know who is right but I think
there's a language barrier something
because I when I first saw this about a
week ago I heard that it was well I read
that it was the girl's brother right
then oh yeah different one yeah because
I saw the video they want a beer right
yeah yeah yeah yeah so there's like oh
we don't know the relation the point is
they tainted they know each other no
yeah yeah buddy's [ __ ] everybody
yep this is not gonna have sound okay
here we go so here they are walking
happily to the stage and then that's
when the video starts to play I believe
wait hold on hurry up and play there we
go and then so immediately he pushes her
and says what you think I didn't know
I saw the video it wasn't impressive
though it's very pg-13 he's like making
out types that late yeah ready okay so
in some more information is that the
couple had been in a relationship for
two years and they got engaged six
months ago and so the groom found out
the groom found out about his bride's
affair after he installed a security
camera during their future home
renovation project so that's how he was
able to find out and then the one that
was pregnant she's six months pregnant
and that's about it for that so this
went very viral in like Chinese media
social media like Mandarin speaking
Cantonese and Taiwanese like all over
and then so all these conspiracy
theories started popping up and they
were like wait a second this seems like
it's a marketing stunt because there is
this logo like plot drama today yeah
yeah there's another twist so they're
saying that there was a logo for a video
platform in that video oh my god dude
they're also saying that like why would
they just air their dirty laundry on a
video website this guy drop like 50 G's
on the wedding poor awesome revenge he's
like I already [ __ ] paid for it like
I'm not gonna let her enjoy that part is
not in the slightest bit suspect
yeah and then also they're saying that
oh that this video app had obtained this
footage exclusively so that was kind of
weird but something else I forgot to add
last - like how did this girl and like
her Sancho got together was because
apparently the
I was having issues with the groom and
that there was like domestic violence
involved somehow
and then so she she oh so then this dude
that she ended up cheating with like the
brother-in-law he would come in and like
try to like defuse the situation between
them and like and so she was like hit
the shoulder to lean on
he was her shoulder to lean on and
that's how they're saying they got close
but they're also some credits after
though because the camera is a little
man on a Trojan box yeah for a little
bit too long from that security footage
where's the love oh I'm actually in the
main video but I didn't see it I didn't
see a logo when I was on the mayor
pointing this this out right here logo I
can't even make it out I had no idea but
if she grabs his dick in the footage
then I doubt that it's an ad can we do
we know she didn't what I saw was just
kissing there was a lot of kiss in the
roses like things just kind of laying
there first like like flirting and not
flirting but like just no necking and
all I didn't lay those over yeah but I
don't see this guy talking about okay oh
yeah I was very disappointed I was like
uh-huh
I'm ready for the juicy you know I lit a
candle there was nothing wasted a match
I stop wasting his time yeah but yeah so
this entire thing went crazy viral cuz
they were just like how could he be so
like driven in his revenge I couldn't
even think of the other guests that were
there like there were children there so
they're like what the [ __ ] you guys
making out so what kids see that [ __ ] in
commercials and stuff all the time
16 you're gonna watch that [ __ ] De
Beers commercial no for her the gift of
love
make out Loosli Lucas said De Beers and
I was thinking like is there a beer and
it was the funniest sounding brand that
I could think of not chaos funny two
beers is funnier jokes yeah you know
whiteboard it for you you say kay
Jewelers doesn't have the ring to it
beers yeah makes a big noise it's weird
enough and you've heard of it you don't
live them you know no way you know when
you break it down like I didn't think I
didn't go directly to the beers when you
said it so I passed the joke to Bart he
left he left right yeah nothin and then
you didn't get them all well I got it
after you said the beers yeah yeah you
got the new at the ball you hit the ball
so TIFF is only one who didn't get the
ball and that's completely acceptable to
get credit if she didn't get it I don't
think she got it either so I think
completely acceptable way again that's
in the circle area okay go okay so she's
not a bit soon Bob Ryan pie I just did
it I just was like the beers is like the
whitest should I've ever heard okay so
what the [ __ ] is the beers
it's a diamond company yeah yeah jewel I
thought you made up a word it's not
unlike white people to make up some [ __ ]
yeah who am I talking to you right now
you I've called yourself multiple times
a liar and then we should never believe
any said literally haven't heard that
yeah so be careful
what about Vlad about Lana oh you're
still a liar lions
prove this point yeah I wasn't even sure
you proved my point I was gonna go the
white board yeah was it for her
hey now you know what the beers is DBE
the beers and their slogan is every kiss
begins with
that's ridiculous
they got sued for it right hey you you
walked by those diamond shops in the
mall and how they're always empty it was
always like four people in there and all
the stand yeah what's up with that are
they watching money
come on I don't know I mean here's the
thing though like it's it's like all
right so when I worked at Carmack's we
were uncommon in the sis of we so
anywhere from like 15 to 30 cars a day
right okay like this that's the best
normal volume for car max right for a
normal traditional car lot they move 15
to maybe 20 a month right so I'm dead
tear yeah it's a lot of dead air but
like what you would you sell that to the
finance company you get 30 to 60
thousand dollars to the company so it's
like if somebody you know we might not
see the people that we're going in there
but like they're going there for a week
and they finally design them decide on a
ring they go in there they spend $7,000
ring it's like okay well we made the
week off of these two three sales you
sell a couple of yeah but I hate what
I'm trying to bring up like a cool
conspiracy and then someone with facts
comes in and ruins it I do it all the
[ __ ] time I see a key little below I
was like there's no girl like pop right
there watch the string I have no way
he's gonna go right before tip said it I
was like oh yes I ruined this [ __ ]
I felt my [ __ ] open just a little bit
like it was a prayer for boy
[Music]